[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
comment améliorer parcoursup
5 ans après son lancement 83% des
usagers trouvent parcours substant selon
l'enquête Ipsos 2022 sur l'opinion des
néo bacheliers à l'égard de la
plateforme d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur si des améliorations ont été
apportées sur le plan technique et sur
le plan informationnel c'est pourtant
une anxiété croissante et un sentiment
de manque de clarté de rapidité d'équité
et de transparence qui semble donc
prédominer chez les usagers pour
analyser cette défiance croissante
envers parcoursup la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication à souhaiter dresser un
état des lieux actualisés de la
procédure devenu une étape majeure dans
le parcours d'orientation des lycéens
à la suite des auditions qu'il a mené le
rapporteur Jacques gros Perrin identifie
trois obstacles principaux à sa bonne
acceptation
premièrement les neobacheliers déplorent
les lacunes et l'hétérogénéité de
l'information délivrée
deuxièmement il se plaignent de la
longueur de la procédure
troisièmement il déplore l'opacité des
modalités de classement afin de
poursuivre l'amélioration de la
plateforme d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur et surtout de rendre celle-ci
plus acceptable auprès des néo
bacheliers Jacques gros Perrin avance
lui proposition pour faciliter le
travail de présentation des formations
et harmoniser leurs pratiques il
convient de mettre à disposition des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
une base lexicale commune
le rapporteur estime qu'une méthodologie
universelle de présentation et
d'évaluation par filière de formation
permettrait de gagner en lisibilité et
en équité afin de réduire le délai
d'attente d'une proposition pour les
candidats qui n'en ont pas et ainsi
accélérer la procédure leur apporteur
suggère également d'avancer la date de
la hiérarchisation des vœux aux
alentours de la mi-juin dans un souci de
transparence il préconise aussi
d'inciter les formations à davantage
préciser les critères définis et
utilisés par leurs commissions d'examen
des vœux à cet égard Jacques gros Perrin
suggère de substituer aux critères du
lycée d'origine un critère plus objectif
fondé sur l'écart de notation existant
entre la moyenne du contrôle continu de
terminale et les résultats au
baccalauréat
en outre il appelle à améliorer les
modalités d'accès des boursiers à
l'enseignement supérieur et invite à
lancer une réflexion sur les moyens
permettant d'adapter parcoursup aux 10%
des candidats qui sont en reprise
d'études enfin l'auteur du rapport
insiste sur l'importance d'assurer un
service public d'accompagnement à
l'orientation au lycée adapté à sa
nouvelle organisation et à la maîtrise
de parcoursup parmi les pistes qu'il
envisage à cet effet revoir
l'organisation et la gestion du service
public de l'orientation en retravaillant
sa dimension territoriale
il s'agit de réfléchir au rôle possible
des différents acteurs locaux région
rectorat lycée et établissement
d'enseignement supérieur
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]